Hey, the Midnight Sun's Evil Eye wanted this, but
how the hell do you know? I mean, I do know who they are.
The elves are the ones who can master
it, but
ah,
elves are
species with anti-magic powers that lived in what we now call the system around five times hundreds of years ago.
There weren't many things like that,
hundreds of years ago, this person's shoes.
But it wasn't that girl who activated the magic in the near future, but someone else.
The
ancient genie is also the king of the elves Saga. It's the highest-level magic that's coming up.
It's amazing that it's about the elves The new upper part is Paris
par
And when you press the
two keys you have It
's the result of the magic sword that many elves used
ber Oh
wow Astak's head is talking  If it did, it exploded
. Stay strong, Panda Star. You're an idiot, so I'm fine with this. It's a
burger.